une simple image symbole de la
compassion et de la souffrance en temps
de pandémie aux états unis le docteur
joseph valeur se souvient très bien de
ce patient en pleurs le jour de l'action
de grâce à l'ennemi le dr varaine tente
de se mêlerait confort comme il peut il
circule dans son unité que vide avec son
portrait autour du cou un peu de chaleur
humaine pour briser l'isolément de ces
patients dans son hôpital communautaire
de houston au texas
88 des 120 lits sont consacrés aux
malades atteints de lakovic 19
son équipe et lui sont épuisés des
strophes maïs aux états unis près de
cent mille personnes sont hospitalisées
en ce moment un sommet on dénombre près
de 2600 décès en 24 heures le personnel
sur la ligne de front et poussé dans ses
derniers retranchements
on ne le montre pas quand on interagit
avec les patients mais c'est tellement
difficile 17 médecins gériatres du
colorado
mais malgré ces drames des millions
d'américains ont défié les directives
sanitaire pendant le congé de l'action
de grâce en voyageant et en faisant des
réunions familiales
le dr varaine ne cache pas sa
frustration au cross people les faits
next 6 607 photos marquantes peut-elle
éveiller les consciences le caillou dans
cette période sombre
une bonne nouvelle le patient sur la
photo va mieux et pourra retrouver sa
femme cette semaine ici louis blouin
radio-canada washington